ich wurde das getötet von jugend typen
bleiben relativ verdächtig vorkamen zu
hacken
wer genau von dem ja
soz s kids und herzlich willkommen zu
einer vorher geländer game center hat
mich ich bin euer steve natürlich habe
ich keinen skin es liegt nicht erst mal
die minecraft so wie ich bin dass wir
komplett sinnfrei sind bezogen heute mit
dem kran zu den crafter ja und ich kann
das so sehen wir das ändern kippte
spielt energie ich weiß was das kann ich
sag dir frieden echt ja wie gesagt wir
zocken heute eine runde ender games mal
wieder seit langem keine kit vorstellung
mehr sondern erzielte entspannte runde
ich spiele das känguru kit wir schon an
meinen weltklasse springer gesehen habt
gut weggekommen känguru sowieso immer
was mit ihr spielt dieser sexy cani
diese sexy kranich spielt glaube ich du
hast zu ändern ändern wenn jetzt groß
angepriesen aber ich habe spieler zum
bomber oder ich mir schon was also er
hat ambitionen das spiel zu gewinnen
übrigens ihr seht vielleicht hier ich
habe ein leicht verändertes texture pack
das ist von ich glaube sein name ist
down kraft oder so wenn wir das gemacht
hat bekommt man sagen berlin
ja ja ja sauber also mein lieber ein
kraftvoller dass ihr siehst wir machen
ja diesen samstag eventuell erneut
entfernt treffen sie mich wahrscheinlich
sogar wenn du kannst dann schau mal
vorbei
da können wir live denn texture pack
diskutieren müssen wir den respekt life
to live dabei
jetzt wirklich nach einem bogen skills
und bis auf einen
ja ich bin ein känguru oder der deftigen
von weg da keine zwanzig sein und mein
alter
jetzt kommt es ganz schön leicht lady
muss ich sagen du bist so hat sie
wiedergeboren
was 45
dann kann ich aber einen freien tag
wieder zeit videos zu machen leute ihr
habt ja wahrscheinlich mitbekommen
jetztzeit was relativ unregelmäßig liegt
einfach daran dass ich ziemlich totalen
robin ja auch ich bin damit minister
eigentlich zahlen muss auch wenn ich
weiß gar nicht warum ich jetzt etwas
anders gesagt hat danke dass sie nicht
so richtig was magst du bist bist der
beste du bisch portal aber ich habe ein
richtig netter kerl sollten stümpel
es ist der crafter im orange gelb
karierten mantel ist so meinolf kate ist
wenn ich keine pariert hatte sowas
bisschen kleiner
das muss jeder wissen so geil ist ich
habe grade eben richtig ausgepackt in
der aufnahme das nicht man keine videos
zurückgesetzt ist klar 6666 reflex every
day ist gerade richtig seltsam irgendwie
aber ich glaube ich hab eine karotte
insofern ist alles in ordnung
ich bin ein
ich hab's geschafft ich habe es gerade
so geschafft hätte es war richtig groß
eltern
kennst du diese momente manchmal wenn
ihr einfach denkst du okay okay das habe
ich niemals niemals das war gerade
ungefähr genauso eine aber es wäre ich
verfolgt von paul und ich stehe als
bomber direkt von akuten angeht aber
sind patrick i ich habe das gerade
telepathische fähigkeit vom ganzen leben
herausgelesen in der küche werkelt
gemacht ich werde euch dann bist du
cheater 01 bist bei mir ja lady maggie
sondern den rennen erst mal was anderes
op grip bei nässe oder den buben heißt
du bist du selber großen dass wir den
zug nicht wieder leute hast du glaub ich
das also hat man den bogen auf jemanden
geschossen
ich hab grad kälter dann etwas was zur
hölle los was für ein böser lag alter
ach du scheiße ist es bitter dass ich
weggehe switch aber ich merke aber so
ein hit von hinten will den trecker
benutzen es kommt keine meldung vom
trecker nach kangaroo sprung habe auf
einmal wieder in freiheit drin natürlich
weiß ist kein freiherr von
fakt dass ich da weiterfliegen kann
fliegt so schön auch immer bin ich tot
und ich hatte wirklich noch sieben
herzen und gute rüstung richtig firma
wal mart mit
deswegen würde ich sagen wir machen
einen kurzen kann so dass wir wieder es
gibt weitere nummer 22 und 10 973 ich
kann nicht weiter zählen bitte ein
bisschen probleme also auch skill
probleme ja genauso wie die probleme ich
meine spielen kann ich zwar nicht im
übrigen liga ist gerade nicht weil mein
lieblingswetter mit besser machen fotos
aber okay ich habe heute den rav ich
habe heute den rafi in der stadt
getroffen und dass ich auch so ein
[ __ ] stellt sich wieder neben nicht
wenn ich weiter vorne wo es böse lady
alter das ist kacke aber gut da müssen
wir jetzt durch wir können schaffen wir
kennen alter kommen auf einmal die
kinder ursprünglich 20.000 sekunden
millionen ja niemals ich werde
zurückgebaut konstant kann nicht sein
hält dieser dieser tommy hat gerade
einen richtigen zu recht als bastard
beschimpft
denn wer einer der mir sachen abgebaut
hat also ich weiß nicht ob dieser tommy
ich ist oder ob nicht dieser tommy bin
aber guter typ ist auf jeden fall die
zuschauer weißt du dass es überhaupt
keinen trend also zumindest der trecker
lag war nicht ich hab ich habe auch ein
neues tier schwer dir vielleicht seht
das feiere ich ziemlich die ich für
dieses t shirt ist fast das ganze online
text effekt
ist etwas für neuer grundlage ist das
allerdings selbst half life als basiert
auf der hand lag bei mir ich hab grad in
sälen dieb gekillt ja gibt mir die level
kontrollfunktion ich kann einfach den
job von uns allen
na klar konnte die nehmen und frauen und
benutzten
aber den kann man nur ein mal platzieren
ach so nee nee ich hab ihm platzierten
ist wiedergekommen
also ja weil er wieder weg in
erweiterten trecker kann man auch nicht
mehr so oft er kann man eben aber der
politologe checken
das wäre deshalb zu op passanten fanden
wir auch kommen ist staub das und
anderes känguru meinikmann kinder ab
nicht so doll also den scan groß ist
jetzt schon ein harter wettbewerb
spammer die leertaste wie ein mongole
weiterkommen im cic eingraviert wurden
von sgs abgetötet echt ja ja klar in den
edeka ich habe ein kind in kiel habe ich
schon selbst gemacht aber er hat halt
hinter mir hat dann den dude abgestaubt
und mich direkt bearbeitet und so
brachten die skater und ich hab ich bin
auch gleich kommen ich bin der von
hinten kommen du bist du bist der
rüstung
wenn er von hinten wo bist du das bist
du das wär ich bin weg du bist nicht 108
denn es ist immer so eine kacke wenn man
nie mit jemand spiele sie gelegt hat
weil das soll ich hab' ich habe als
känguru jemanden mit ketchup getötet ja
man muss manchmal ist das bisschen magie
guck mal ich kommentiere ich muss gar
nicht richtig aufpassen
ich kann es gar nicht
nicht du bist echt aufpassen
ich habe drei herzen obwohl jetzt schon
eine weile
direkt habe wie heißt der titel der
richterskala
aber ich muss dringend regen ich bin ja
ich war halt kurz war kurz war am arsch
gern jung das war richtig heftig auf
ammann sieht die eltern nehmen wir die
kuh schlägt ja und ich denke für schon
scheiße doppelsprung und dann will ich
noch stillen im flug von der explosion
weiter nach vorne
aber es war ja noch aus das sind die
schlimmsten momente in ender games ich
weiß nicht ob ihr das kind liebe es
kerzen jetzt wenn ihr einfach die
känguru spielt und ihr job macht und
doppelsprung fliegt und landet dann so
langsam seid ihr begriff zu landen und
seht nur wie der typ einfach aufs tier
zu retten ihr euch zu denken
das erinnert mich so übel an star wars
wo die beiden jungs weil diese eine
szene wo sie denn todesstelle angreifen
und dann immer weiter der rebellen
explodieren und die piloten immer so
machen also die haben die arme so vom
gesicht verschränken daran erinnert mich
das jetzt wisst ihr was in meinem kopf
abgeht
ich würde dort getötet von jungen typen
werden wir relativ verdächtig vorkamen
zu hacken der genau von dem was das
alter bist du mich verarschen
willst du mich verarschen also entweder
ich hatte volle leben das kann sein oder
der hat gehackt weil er hat mich mit
drei jetzt darum gehabt ich kann immer
mit drei hits ja ich mag ich ja ich
meine dass ich voller herzen gehabt
hätte also leute ihr könnt ihr mal in
die aufnahme schauen und es mir in die
kommentare schreiben wie es aussah
meinte der heydt gehackt schreibt in die
kommentare
das ist ungefähr die frage nach jeder
ende games folge leider ist aufgabe
bisschen viel hecking unterwegs aber ich
würde sagen lasst eine positive
bewertung der schreibt es in die
kommentare
ob der kollege gehackt hat und alles
andere was ich da auf der seele liegt
ich will auch irgendwie dr sommer und so
alles also ja ein spaß ihr könnt alles
in die kommentare schreiben was ich so
einfällt und würde ich sagen simon zum
nächsten video wieder
ich hoffe es hat euch gefallen haut rein
und